you
hey thank you for letting me do this
this is actually this is a lot of fun
for me I have to say with all sincerity
this is by far the most difficult
presentation I have ever done period
that is very very true statement it took
me a lot of time to put this together
because one because of the audience I'll
talk a little bit about this audience in
a little bit as we go forward and the
other because we have a lot of ad-hoc
things in life that happen and I go okay
I got to talk about this experience and
as I'm trying to build the thing I go
well actually I don't even know what I
learned from that experience so I don't
even know how to communicate it to you
but I think it'll be informative I hope
it'll be informative a little bit of
background about me just to kind of
color what we're doing I have a very odd
background to be here I went to Penn
State undergrad and then I went and I
was in our Air Force Reserve Officer
Training Corps at that Penn State and
then I went straight to pilot training
Williams Air Force Base in Arizona I
graduated there after a year then I
became a t37 instructor pilot at
Williams before the base closed in 1992
this is the t37 it's a twin-engine it's
actually retired now but it's a fully
aerobatic spin type aircraft high
performance puts very very very slow but
I flew this for a couple years and then
the base closed and I went off to fly
the e3 AWACS frisbee around the world I
did a lot of although it says Tinker Air
Force Base I was deployed this was
during peacetime I was deployed 300 days
a year I was particularly in Saudi
Arabia Turkey watching the northern and
southern no-fly zones of Iraq before the
second Iraq war and then also doing a
lot of counter drug stuff out of Panama
so we would go and do counter drug
surveillance looking for low-flying
aircraft over the Caribbean so I did
that for four years and then I went back
to the t37 this is actually my last
flight in the airforce
that is yes Penn State cheerleader
Barbie
I was a t37 instructor at the instructor
school I was also an evaluator pilot
I'll talk about that experience in a few
minutes and I was a spin demonstration
pilot and then I got out and I went to
get a PhD at Penn State and then at the
time Penn State had a fantastic ph.d
program in accounting one of the better
ones we were placing people at MIT
Harvard we placed somebody at
Northwestern and Wharton and of course I
landed here I do research an
insider-trading exec comp financial
reporting standards and international
accounting and I teach the International
Accounting Advanced Course here I should
say I taught because I am leaving the
school this year and we'll talk about
that if you want later but I'm not going
to bring that through here I have two
daughters and a son a brand-new baby
he's eight months old
and they love to draw pictures for you
and today is no exception
so that's that's that's Ryan Taylor and
Megan why was I selected variety the
spread as such I actually have no idea
okay well I'll tell you what I think is
it because of this I'm closer to dead
than you in fact
you seen the friended me Kathy in fact
I'm right here I might get at this scary
part where I'm halfway dead so I have
more to talk about than you do and you
guys are still partying in foam and I'm
changing diapers I also owe the academic
committee a lot of money and they are
extracting rent from me so there were 25
take your professor to lunches at $15
gift cards to 375 bucks I owe you guys
so this is part of that compensation why
don't you agree to do this talk I think
it's extremely important to stop and
reflect on where you've been before you
step out and go further and this is an
opportunity for me to do that I also
think this is extremely important for me
I actually believe that you can be more
successful if you internalize other
people's experiences from some reason
teenagers have a very difficult time
doing that and they have to learn on
their own through their own pain but
sometimes I actually watch what other
people do and maybe you can learn from
my personal experience I also think it's
important for me to implicitly honor
some of the people who had a material
impact in my life I would not be here
for without the help of several people
I'm not going to talk a lot about them
unfortunately but this is implicitly
honoring them and also I'm trying to get
more free lines
I am free some next week okay so here's
what we're gonna cover it was very
difficult for me to kind of collapse
this so I'm gonna go through an
experiential lesson about whistleblowing
some perspective for the ambitious
because I'm extremely ambitious and I
know that you are and I'm actually
struggling with an issue that all that
we'll discuss with you and I suspect
many of you will have the same issue
going forward some thoughts about
vulnerability relationships because many
of you are at an age where you are
considering or you are entering
long-term relationships and I have some
serious fundamental philosophies about
that and then some pretty cool closing
thoughts
so it's kind of ambitious but here we go
this is the whistle blowing this is a
serious thing and I know you don't
understand what this thing is so let me
explain this we don't need a lot of this
but I was flying as an evaluator pilot
in the t37 we had a brand new lieutenant
colonel I'm a captain he's a lieutenant
colonel he's a fighter pilot so he
outranks me by a lot he's coming into
the our squadron leadership and she is
again he's a fighter pilot so I kind of
deferred wow this guy's flown a lot of
and he's had a lot of experience he's
also going to be part of our squadron
cadres so there's a fraternity in our
squadron we kind of take care of each
other so we're flying this mission and
he does a bunch of stupid things in the
area and I'm not allowed to talk to him
throughout the entire flight so I'm just
sitting there as a passenger and we're
flying in and we're doing a typical
instrument approach into Kelly Air Force
Base in San Antonio and what this means
this is the approach to the runway to
the north this is an approach to the
runway to the north here this here this
1,040 is an altitude called a minimum
descent altitude any pilots in the room
nobody ok it's a minimum descent
altitude which for this particular
approach you are not at all even one
foot supposed to go below that altitude
unless you're in a position visually to
hit the glide path and you can go in for
the landing so you have to see the
runway you have to be on glide path
before you can descend below that
altitude so we're flying along we are
not in a position to get to the glide
path and he drops 200 feet below that
altitude which is a checkride bust for
any human being in the airforce period
it's a clear bust it's over and part of
the reason why is because eight hundred
forty feet puts me 27 feet below this
this obstacle right here this is a set
of towers and it's actually 200 feet
below those other towers and so I go
altitude and he raises he climbs finally
back up to altitude and we get down on
the ground and I go okay what do I do
with this guy who's gonna be one of my
leaders in the squadron and he outranks
him by a lot he's a fighter pilot and
we're a fraternity how do I handle this
and it's really embarrassing to go
through this and I said okay so here's
the deal
you screwed up I should bust you and he
goes oh I know I'm so sorry won't happen
again
on and on and on and on I didn't bust
him it was a clear-cut bust so he's in a
position where he has no thrust to make
the runway he doesn't have time to
restart the engine they eject they get
injured but not severely and the
airplane crashes it's a brand-new
aircraft they haven't even transitioned
people on it the airplanes toast so the
taxpayers are all through their money
away on that and it was completely on a
void
it was completely avoidable rather
completely avoidable and the funny thing
is I sit back and I heard about this and
I go you know I could have pulled him
out and I should have pulled him out
because there were so many instances
during this flight when I was as
evaluator when I could have said this is
crap you're done until we get you
through a flight evaluation process and
that's the process that they go through
if you bus check rides and you needed to
be evaluated in fact I don't think his
head was in the game but I defer to the
fact that he was in a higher ranking
position he was an important person to
the squadron and I felt kind of
compelled to do it
and so you map this into your due
diligence meetings I mean it doesn't
take a lot I think for me to kind of map
this in to where you guys are going
there are a lot of decisions that are to
be made where you're going to be in an
opportunity where you smell it out and
you sniff it out and you kind of know it
doesn't smell right you got to make the
call you have to make the call because
the implications could be severe
particularly now you're we're seeing all
kinds of fallout in the economic markets
where people didn't blow the whistle and
didn't make the call and people are
getting hurt as a result I'm actually
very thankful I said I don't know what's
happening to this guy or what's happened
to him I have to believe he retired but
I'm very thankful nobody got killed here
because very easily I mean this is this
is on approach when they ejected they
were on approach to final and there's
all kinds of buildings underneath these
approach patterns so nobody got killed
out of that so that's my whistleblowing
story hopefully that resonates for you
this thing is something a little bit
we're going to transition to something I
actually feel very strongly about and
this isn't perspective for the ambitious
let's start with the set of all human
beings and then let's jump over and say
hey we're fortunate to now be in the set
of all human beings domiciled in an
economically advantaged country or we
could say we're wealthy now let's say
hey we're actually better than that
we're in the set of all college
graduates so I feel very fortunate to be
in the set of all college graduates I
went
further dustin you here Dustin's not
here anyway Dustin and I are far the set
of all Air Force officers because he
went to the Air Force Academy that's a
pretty elite set if you think about the
unconditional probability of going
through college and getting an Air Force
commissioned is a very very small set of
people it's a very elite group and it
actually is a fraternity in implicit
fraternity so we're proud to be part of
that set but you know what I'm actually
I actually got to a better sit than
heated because I was an Air Force pilot
and I say that jokingly but it's
actually serious because that's how
people think in the Air Force I'm sorry
that's how the pilots think in the Air
Force
that's not how everybody thinks in the
Air Force but I will tell you that the
pilots think that they're the better set
so I'm part of the set of the Air Force
pods but I'm not a fighter pilot and I
want to be a fighter pilot and I'm not a
fighter pilot and you know what funny is
all of my fighter pilot friends are
pissed because they're not weapons
school graduates and all the weapons
school graduates are pissed because
they're not on the fast track for
promotion let's map it into another one
this one I'm living today instead of all
human being sort of all literate human
beings instead of all college graduates
set of all PhDs how many people in the
world have PhDs very few almost nobody
relatively speaking how many of them are
elite school professors do you have any
idea what the probability is of somebody
being able to stand here in front of you
have any idea how low the probability is
when you take a look at that right
that's not good enough cuz I want to be
tenured I want to be tenured and I'm
living with this right now because
that's an uncertain outcome if you
continue to select into more seks
successful peer groups sooner or later
you will become the left tail of your
reference distribution
you're at Stanford University there are
Nobel laureates here they're smarter
than you you're already in the left tail
probably especially if you're Matt
Armstrong um is he here he's not here
okay I can pick up Matt then okay I'm
gonna pick up Matt this I think is very
critical okay because we're ambitious we
want to continue but the problem is it
is it is important you should be
ambitious I'm ambitious I will always be
ambitious the problem here is that
ambition is is addictive I'll admit it
I'm addicted to ambition an ambitious
person might consider this to be a
failure and this could be wealth I see
it in my community I live in Woodside I
know that I'm not a millionaire I'd like
to be a millionaire and I can tell you
definitively without naming names
I know millionaires that are not happy
that they're just millionaires I know
them I can name them if you want but I
won't this could be intellectual
distribution this is the left-tail
dilemma this can be considered a failure
and almost every one of you at some
point will face this I am living it it
in my mind seems important to find
perspective because if you end up
sitting at the right of the next lower
group so if you remember the next lower
group is somewhere over here and if
you're over at the right if you're in
here you're at the left
what experience I've had is if you make
it to the elite group you're probably
not respected well in that elite group
you're probably the lowest ranking
person in that elite group and so you're
not just clear it's a good thing to be
in that elite group but if you don't you
might actually have a better fit and be
more productive over just to the just to
the left of that group or it might be a
good time to look for something
different to do so that's the takeaway
this is what I'm wrestling with but I
think it's very critical because I think
you are all ambitious and I guarantee
you that many of you in this room will
hit this if you have not yet already the
thing is you guys are still early enough
in your careers that you may not have
gotten that far because you're still
kind of working the ambition ladder but
you're gonna hit this this is something
I think is kind of cool because this
reminds me of me and you when I went
through pilot training the very first
thing we did was
discuss stuff before we ever flew an
airplane and and they said okay you guys
fit a certain pilot personality profile
and I actually borrowed this from some
research that's out there about what a
typical pilot particularly a military
pilot is in kind of a personality and I
think that these kind of map in to you
folks emotionally stable low anxiety low
impulsiveness except for matt armstrong
conscientious competent high
assertiveness high achieving and what I
find particularly interesting and per is
this low sense of vulnerability because
we're control animals and we were like
hey I'm in control I got it all covered
I'm a risk you know I know how to assess
risks and I don't feel particularly
vulnerable but we're all vulnerable and
I'll illustrate how I was vulnerable um
February 8 1991 I was finally Captain
John black I was a t-38 student pilot in
the supersonic jet it was about the 11th
month of the 12-month pilot training
program and we're flying at March Air
Force Base which is now closed it's
actually Air Reserve Base this is the
runway layout this is runway 3 - which
means we're heading 3 to 0 on a compass
when we're heading taking off so we're
heading 3 to 0 off of this runway we're
heading up that direction it's at night
on a night navigation mission and
because of the winds are coming from the
right they're coming from the east I
drift a little bit when I take off
that's natural it's called crabbing so
so that you can maintain your course you
crab in to the wind as you take off so
my compass is three-30 when I get a call
from from tower saying turn to one five
zero turn to a heading one five zero
pilots know that they always turn in the
shortest direction unless they're told
otherwise and so I look down and go well
hell it's 180 degrees it doesn't matter
which direction I do I'm going to turn
right so I started to a climbing right
turn three seconds later I get a call
confirm you're in a left turn two one
five zero i go negative i'm in a right
turn two one five zero and at that point
john black goes into full afterburner
raises the nose almost straight vertical
and starts a left bank turn and we
almost took out that tower i was about
20 feet from that town
February 5th 1992 I was an instructor
pilot with Mike wood who was flying my
airplane and this is now a lieutenant
colonel I won't name who it is one of my
better students actually anyway he he
was flying lead solo so this guy is
flying lead solo and Mike woods flying
my airplane I'm sitting on the
right-hand seat and we're flying a two
ship I'll show you how close these are
in a minute we're actually three feet
apart three foot wingtip clearance
that's at 250 miles an hour three feet
apart and he orders a pitch out which
means we're gonna do this maneuver I'll
show you a video of this in a second
we're gonna do maneuver he's gonna turn
first and we're gonna wait a few seconds
and turn behind him and do some trail
manoeuvring this is one of the most
absolute and eric' maneuvers you can
possibly have so this is how close we
typically fly and you see two examples
of a pitch out the first is to the left
so this is a left pitch out where the
lead goes first and then the wingman
goes afterwards and then you'll see it
to the right in a second so there's a
actually the guy who went too fast
there's must wait longer so this guy
turns this guy turns into me I don't
know what the hell he was thinking he
clearly wasn't because he turns into me
so we're already three feet apart 80
turns into me and these are a very
aggressive turns so I mean I'm not even
flying my airplane I immediately jam a
stick full forward as fast as I can we
go up negative G's and we hit our head
into the ceiling and he flies over us by
about 4 inches last vulnerability 1 some
of you guys have seen this this is Matt
Captain Michael ah so he was a friend of
mine we were flying a low-level mission
there was a this isn't San Antonio there
was a lot of smoke in the air so we had
low visibility because of all these
Mexican wildfires and so we're final
level mission he yells bird I look up
there's a big black thing in my face and
this is a 14 pound turkey vulture that
missed my head went over the top and
impacted the tail of the airplane
so what's my point here even when you
think you're in full control you're
incredibly vulnerable to environmental
forces this should seem obvious and
particularly for this group you of all
people given the experiences that you've
had with your cohorts since you've been
here should recognize just how
vulnerable we are as human beings we're
extremely vulnerable as human beings
even when you think you've got your
together your vulnerability increases
with success the more successful you are
the more vulnerable you become because
you get complacent I saw in the Air
Force
over and over again I lived it I was
extremely complacent when I was
finishing up my flying tour because I
was bored and I've done it before when
you get successful you get complacent
you also have increased tolerance for
risk and you also get rent seeking
threats particularly if your success is
financial your vulnerability increases
and what's funny is your sense of
vulnerability typically goes down and so
I think it's important to continually
recognize and embrace your vulnerability
I think it's I have a term for called
healthy paranoia and I think it allows
you to stay visible it's ward off
threats and help you stay grounded as a
human being in fact I think the more you
recognize that you're vulnerable the
more you can actually interact with kids
and interact with your family that
doesn't mean be completely paranoid but
it means recognize that you're human and
the sad part is often it takes some sort
of tragedy to somebody else to bring us
back to this relationships
I know a lot about relationships you
guys are entering into long-term
relationships now because you're at that
age where you start thinking about
relationships in more of a long-term
basis and one of the things that I don't
think you're considering is that your
career is also a relationship I'll talk
about that in a minute
but I can't say this strongly enough the
number one most important thing you need
for a relationship is fundamental
compatibility I can't say that enough if
you don't have fundamental compatibility
it's not why it's not happening it's not
working long term it will not happen in
order to get there you have to have to
have to know what it is you must be able
to do and what it is you absolutely will
not tolerate and I use The Bachelor is
the perfect example to illustrate this
who watches The Bachelor yeah I know I'm
Eunice so the Bachelorette starts Monday
and I'm open to a Skype chat room if
anybody's interested Monday 9 o'clock
but let's take a look at the bachelor
history this this chart thankfully to
frisky comm I've never been there before
but The Frisky icon had this chart and
it shows you all the relationships that
they've had all they're missing a couple
on the end here but they show you the
success factors of all the relationships
that they've put together and actually
they claim that these two are still
together but in fact they're not because
because Mary Mary actually hid Byron and
actually had to go to jail for that
so they don't they don't work well why
don't they work well because they're not
fundamentally they're not fundamentally
compatible how do I know they're not
fundamentally compatible you can see it
you can taste it you can watch it they
don't understand each other number one
number two the type of people that have
to go on national reality television to
find somebody fail to know what it is
they're about I think that's my opinion
so what happened with Brad what happened
with Brad somebody come on
laughs with Brad what happened on Brad
season say that guy he turned them both
down thank you
very nicely done thank you very much I
think that's critical why is that
critical the media went ape over that
the media said oh he's an idiot he sort
of picked one and how could he possibly
do I know this guy's a hero because he
recognized that he absolutely will not
give up what he believes in to hang out
with somebody who's incompatible and I
actually find the guy to be a hero in
fact I think he's probably besides
there's one that has that still together
they have babies and stuff like that but
but besides them so there's one success
story that I'm aware of but besides them
I think this is this is the role model
here make sure you know what you want
before you get into a long-term
relationship and you have to be
fundamentally compatible for
relationships including your career your
career is a relationship you spend more
time there than you do at home many of
you seek transition when the challenge
fades I actually put all of you that's
why you're here many of you have a very
strong sense of social responsibility
most of you actually all of you like to
call the shots and all of you have a
very low tolerance for inefficiency in
waste
trust me I've taught you before
here's what I think you'll miss most
here's what I know you'll miss most
here's what I won't miss most you ready
to cry daily interaction with the most
impeccably selected collection of the
brightest most genuine most energetic
most interesting people in the world you
will never ever ever get an opportunity
except at reunion to be around this
cohort in this caliber again in your
entire life these people are fantastic
they're fascinating they're very
interesting why do I go to lunch with
you because it's interesting I actually
get asked by the faculty why are you
going to launch the students because
they're interesting more interesting
than you are know that well when you
hang when you hang around Dave Larker
long enough I love Dave sorry sorry Dave
you know III don't
I'm not joking here I actually think
this is true you will miss this dearly
and you should because you're gonna be
around smart people because you select
into being around smart people but you
will never get in you'll never get the
daily interaction with this kind of
group ever again and you will miss this
and I hope you missed this I've been
asking this question for about - about
100 100 Air Force Academy applicants so
I was an Air Force Academy liaison
officer and I would interview high
school students for the Air Force
Academy the first question I would ask
them is who was influential in your life
every one of them could answer that
question I then would follow up with
this type of a question say okay who has
who who would say that you are actually
one of the most important people in
their lives and they all stumbled and
stopped they could not answer this
question granted they were younger than
you and I know some of you have been
able to answer this this was a chance
for you to hopefully self reflect what I
think this is important about this is
that I need you I'm asking you to please
expand this list I don't care what's on
the list I don't care how deep it is I
don't care if it even exists but I hope
that you go home and start tomorrow to
expand this list and here's why I can't
give you a more sincere compliment than
this you guys are the role models for my
children
it took me six years to come to that
realization but when I think about the
types of human beings in this world that
I actually want my kids to grow up to be
except for Matt Armstrong you guys sorry
Matt I love you too but no seriously
though I mean these are the tie mean
you're not gonna get a better City
you're really not gonna get a better set
and the fact that you're actually in
this room and at this institution
indicates that somebody took an active
role in mentoring you as you got here
and it's time for you to kind of pay
that back I'm going to close off by
saying this look it's very hard to come
up with an idea of how to distill 42
years of life into something that's
meaningful for a group of people who are
already at Stanford Business School and
I actually appreciate the opportunity
because it allowed me a great chance to
think a lot about stuff that I've done
in a pleasure and an honor to do this
and I appreciate the time